it's almost as though Western science  was fascinated by energy for five  thousand years we pursued understanding  energy and this process ends with  thermal nuclear explosions in the  deserts of the American Southwest we can  light the fire that burns in the heart  of the distant stars we know how to do  that that's what the Western mind  achieved political issues assigned the  Eastern mind was not interested in  energy it was interested in tiling and  they spent 5,000 years deconstructing it  looking at it and you don't use out of  smashes you don't use enormous physical  pressure it's a different problem and  you bring different tools to bear you  meditate you look inside yourself you  study the moon movement of water around  pebbles you consider the situation you  study history  you